YOUR WIFE AND DAUGHTER TOO.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US, WE
APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: SO THE HEALTH OF
THE PEOPLE TRYING TO SAVE OUR
HEALTH IS OF REAL CONCERN.
SO WE WANT TO PAUSE NOW AND READ
A COUPLE OF LETTERS WE RECEIVED,
BOTH FROM NURSES IN
NEW YORK CITY.
THEY’VE ASKED US TO LEAVE THEIR
NAMES OUT.
THESE ARE REAL AND WE WANT TO
SHARE THEM WITH YOU.
HERE’S THE FIRST.
"I’M CURRENTLY IN ISOLATION
BECAUSE I WAS EXPOSED TO A COVID
POSITIVE PATIENT 12 DAYS AGO.
IN MY UNIT RIGHT NOW, WE’RE JUST
WEARING YOUR REGULAR GOWN,
FACE MASK WITH OUR EYES AND HEAD
EXPOSED.
THEM HAD ONE THERMAL SCANNER THE
ENTIRE UNIT.
IN THE ISOLATION ROOM IS VERY
SMALL, TEN BY 12 FEET WITHOUT
ANY VENTILATION.
WE DO THE ENTIRE PROCEDURE
FACE-TO-FACE WITH THE PATIENT,
JUST ALL REGULAR MASK AND GOWN,
EVEN WHEN THEY SHOW SIGNS AND
SYMPTOMS OF COVID-19.
I’M ON MY EIGHTH DAY OF
ISOLATION, EXPERIENCE AND
COUGHING WITH A RUNNY NOSE,
POUNDING HEADACHES, AND
DIARRHEA.
I’VE TRIED TO CALL HOTLINES THEY
ARE GIVING TO PEOPLE OF NEW YORK
TO GET TESTED, AND THEY’RE
TURNING IT ME DOWN.
I’M TERRIFIED BECAUSE I SUFFER
FROM ASTHMA AND SUFFER FROM
DIABETES.
MY SON, HAS A LIFELONG
CONDITION, SOMETHING HAPPENS TO
ME.
MY HUSBAND IS ALSO A HEALTH CARE
WORKER AT ONE OF THE BIGGEST
HOME CARE SERVICES IN NEW YORK,
THEY ARE ALSO NOT PROVIDING THE
NECESSARY PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT BECAUSE IT IS STILL
NOT MANDATED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH FOR ALL HEALTH CARE
WORKERS TO WEAR THE PROPER PPE.
NEW YORK CITY HAS A SHORTAGE OF
SUPPLIES AND WE ARE NOT YET AT
THE PEAK.
THE SITUATION HERE IS ONLY GOING
TO GET WORSE.
"
HERE’S A SELECT AND FROM SECOND
LETTER.
"THERE IS ABOUT TRIPLE THE USUAL
INFLUX OF PATIENTS BEING REELED
INTO THE E.R.
MANY PATIENTS ARE SENT HOME
WITHOUT BEING TESTED BECAUSE
THEY DON’T MEET ALL THE
CRITERIA.
THERE’S ALWAYS A LINGERING FEAR
THAT SOMEONE WAS AND HOW MIGHT
ACTUALLY BE SICK.
OF THE HOSPITAL IS RESTRUCTURING
TO ACCOMMODATE THE NUMBER OF
COVID-19 CASES.
TODAY, ABOUT 80% OF BEDS ARE
BEING USED FOR COVID-19
PATIENTS.
WE HAD 20 CASES LAST WEEK, AND
TODAY, OVER 100.
THERE’S A LOT OF PRESSURE,
BECAUSE WE NURSES HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO ALL PATIENTS,
AND AT THE SAME TIME, WE FEAR
GETTING SICK AND GETTING OUR
FAMILIES SICK.
IT’S A VERY TENSE ENVIRONMENT
RIGHT NOW.
IN THE PAST WEEK, WE HAD A
PATIENT COME IN FOR NONCOVID
RELATED PROCEDURES.
AFTER, THEY SAID THEY HAD BEEN
EXPOSED, AND SURE ENOUGH, TESTED
POSITIVE.
THINGS LIKE THIS MAKE US ALL
SUSPICIOUS AND ON EDGE ALL THE
TIME.
THE NURSES WERE ANGRY BECAUSE WE
WERE NOT ALL GIVEN N-95 MASKS
UNTIL THIS WEEK AND WE ARE TOLD
THEY ARE NOT ENOUGH.
THEY PUT OUR NAMES ON EQUIPMENT
BECAUSE WE ARE TO BETTER KEEP
REUSING THEM, AND ARE INSTRUCTED
TO KEEP OUR END-95 MASKS UNTIL
THEY ARE SOILED, AND WE KEEP THE
MASKS AND BAGS SO WE CAN REUSE